well folks uh
I'm here at FEMA headquarters to thank
homeless security secretary mayorkas
come down on the Coast Guard Fagan
and the Commanding General the Army
Corps of Engineers Lieutenant General
Spellman
and the FEMA administrator who's become
the MVP here these days I spent a lot of
time in this room uh griswell of FEMA
and an entire Workforce and on many
other federal agencies that are working
together here you know they're always
going to be above and beyond the running
toward danger and to save lives most
people want to run away from it these
guys run toward it and it really matters
and it really matters and they're
helping survivors that are really in
desperate need and that's what we're
doing as we focus on delivering help to
the people directly impacted by
Hurricane and
I'm going to use this
it made landfall yesterday
and it is still still moving across the
state today
this could be the deadliest hurricane in
Florida's history
the numbers of still are still unclear
but we're hearing early reports of what
may be substantial loss of life and
parenthetically I should note I've
spoken with the governors and the Mayors
and the Commissioners I've been on the
phone with the governor this morning
I spoke with Commissioners and Mayors
and uh they are they are worried but
they are every one of them are telling
me what an incredible job is being done
to save their cities their towns their
counties their ports their Bridges
Etc
and in the face of serious danger search
and rescue operations got on our way
before Dawn this morning
for people stranded and who are in
Desperate shape
water rescue is critical Coast Guard
deployed 16 Rescue helicopters sixth
Wing aircraft and 18 rescue boats and
Crews
that's just one element of the many
federal search and rescue teams that the
pre-stage in Florida and the governor
talked about how impressed he was with
the Coast Guard is doing this morning
these are dangerous missions and I'm
grateful for the brave women and men in
federal state and local governments
working as one team risking their lives
to save others and we're going to learn
a lot more in the coming hours
but we know many families are hurting
many many are hurting today and our
entire country hurts with them because
it's been all over the country we've
seen so many crises but in Florida today
is a sen is a is the epicenter we're
continuing to see deadly rainfall
catastrophic Storm surges roads and
homes flooded we're seeing millions of
people without power and thousands
hunkered down in schools and community
centers they're wondering what's going
to be left what's going to be left when
they get to go home quote unquote home
or even if they have a home to go to
some of the folks have been through this
before but that doesn't make it any
easier actually makes the anxiety even
higher in my view my message to people
of Florida the country is at times like
this America comes together
we're going to pull together as one team
as one America first thing this morning
as I talked to Governor DeSantis and
again offered the fullest Federal
support earlier this week I approved his
request for the pre-landfall Emergency
declaration to provide direct federal
assistance to the state for emergency
protective measures to save lives
including search and rescue and shelter
and food
early this morning I approved the
governor's most recent request for the
expedited major disaster declaration
that means the federal government will
cover 100 percent of the cost to clear
debris and for all the costs the state
has to do has to engage in and expend to
save lives
the federal government will also cover a
majority of the cost of rebuilding
public buildings like schools and State
Fire Stations and folks in Florida who
have
destroyed or damaged homes you don't
have enough Insurance it means the
federal government will provide
individual assistance of thirty seven
thousand nine hundred dollars for home
repairs another thirty seven thousand
nine hundred dollars for lost property
for everything from the automobile to a
lost wedding ring that's that's what we
mean by Lost Property I've also spoken
with Mayors across the state both
Republican and Democrat and I've told
them the same thing we are here
whether you need and whatever you need I
indicated to call me directly at the
White House they know how to do that
we're going to do everything we can to
provide whatever they need we've
dispatched over 1 000 FEMA personnel and
pre-position major federal capacities
and capabilities and supplies that
includes millions of liters of water
millions of meals and hundred hundreds
of generators I deployed dozens of
search and rescue teams along with high
water vehicles and Rescue helicopters to
help get survivors of safety thousands
thousands of National Guard members have
been activated and in my direction the
Department of Defense is providing surge
capacity on multiple fronts in support
of FEMA's efforts I also want to say
again to everyone in Ian's path the
danger is real to State the obvious
Please obey all warnings and directions
from emergency officials and while the
water is receding don't go outside
unless you absolutely have to it's risky
for you and an impeased First Responders
from doing their job I also want to say
again to the oil and gas Executives do
not do not do not use this storm as an
excuse to raise gasoline prices or gouge
the American public
the price of oil has dropped in recent
weeks the price of gas should be going
down as rapidly as not
my experts inform me the production of
only about 160 000 barrels a day has
been impacted by this storm that's less
than two percent of our country's daily
production it's small and temporary
impact on oil production provides no
excuse no excuse for price increases at
the pump period if a gas station
companies try to use this storm to raise
prices I'm going to ask I'm going to ask
officials to look into whether or not
price gouging is going on
America is watching and the industry
should do the right thing I expect them
to do the right thing
and while we're seeing the devastating
images in Florida
I want to be clear
to the people of Puerto Rico
were not gone away I am committed to you
and the recovery of the island
will stand by you for however long it
takes to get it done
I know the folks here at famine across
the federal government are working
non-stop Around the Clock
that's why that's why finally I want to
thank the First Responders the National
Guard the Coast Guard service members
and the search and rescue Personnel who
are working to get people to safety and
to restore power water and phone lines
and I want to thank everyone here at
FEMA and other Federal Personnel I've
seen you in action all across the
country from the west coast to the
Northwest to the Northeast down in
Louisiana all across this country and
just in the last two weeks you've been
working 24 7. no matter what and what
America no matter what and when
emergencies happen FEMA is always there
you deserve the nation's gratitude and
full support
and right now if you're in the National
Guard and you get called up you can
still keep your job
but if you're in a FEMA Reserve that's
not the case
that's why early this morning I signed
the law the bipartisan crew Act
championed by the in the Senate by Gary
Peters and Rob Portman and the house by
Dina Titus and John Kate excuse me catco
and we signed it that law will ensure
that FEMA reservists have job protection
just like military service just like
military service so when you're called
up
to help with the disaster you can now
focus on that mission without worrying
you might lose your job your day job or
receive some other penalty at work
because of this national service that's
what the crew act guarantees
it's going to help people become more
civilian gain more civilian reservists
out there and it's going to make FEMA
stronger it's going to make America
stronger that's who we are every time
disaster strikes emergency crews from
all over the country all over the
country from across the federal
government show up to help like they're
doing right now in Florida that's
America
a country of women and men willing to
serve willing to leave their own
families to help with strangers family
everyone hard at work in Florida right
now deserves our thanks and when the
conditions allow it I'm going to be
going to Florida to thank them
personally so we don't get in the way
I'll do our best we're going to do our
best to build Florida back as quickly as
possible we're not going to be leaving
we're going to build it back with the
state and local government however long
it takes we're going to be there that's
my commitment to you I want to now turn
it over to secretary mayorkas
plan to meet with Governor santis when
you're down there
with everybody who's around
the answer is yes if he wants to meet
that's my intention
thank you very much Mr President
our hearts go out to the people in the
affected areas at DHS our highest
priorities the preservation of life and
safety DHS is working with our federal
state local and non-governmental
Partners to support the needs of the
areas that are and may be impacted by
Hurricane Ian I want to thank the
president for his leadership in signing
the major disaster declaration that
unlocks critical assistance to help
jumpstart impacted Floridians road to
recovery
FEMA and the United States Coast Guard
are focused on life-saving and
life-sustaining response operations and
we are launching the recovery mission
the Coast Guard has completed extensive
preparations in advance of hurricane Ian
to minimize impacts to Maritime Commerce
ensure Public Safety and position
ourselves for a rapid response currently
the Coast Guard is aircraft Cutters
flood response assets and response
Personnel staged throughout Florida
ready for immediate deployment
FEMA has teams in place who are ready to
help those who need it most we have
thousands of our Personnel deployed
throughout the Department of Homeland
Security not only from FEMA and the
United States Coast Guard but also from
our cyber security and infrastructure
Security Agency and from TSA
today I will be activating the DHS surge
capacity Force so that we can bring to
bear additional Personnel from across
the department to support disaster
survivors in Florida when a catastrophic
event hits DHS approaches response and
Recovery work with a full expanse of our
resources and our capabilities our work
in support of those affected by Ian will
continue in the days weeks and months to
come this is not just a here today and
gone tomorrow we are here as the
president has articulated throughout the
need for full recovery in that regard
with respect to Puerto Rico as the
president mentioned yesterday I approved
a temporary and targeted Jones act
waiver to ensure that the people of
Puerto Rico have sufficient diesel to
run generators needed for electricity
and the functioning of critical
facilities as they recover from
Hurricane Fiona we are in it for the
long haul now it's my pleasure to turn
it over to administrator Deanne Criswell
of FEMA
thank you Mr secretary I would first
like to Again Begin by thanking the
president for being here in FEMA's
national response coordination Center
this is the heartbeat of what we do
right here this is where we bring the
federal family together these are some
amazing public servants
I'd also like to thank the president for
signing the crew ACT earlier this
morning
Mr President behind us here are
dedicated public servants from across
the federal Family behind us are the
dedicated public servants who have been
working tirelessly day in and day out to
get help to those who need us most
these are the dedicated public servants
who have put the needs of others before
their own and these are the public
servants that we count on to respond to
America's worst day
this is what the full force of the
federal family looks like right here
behind me
I'd like to recognize every single
person here as well as those on the
ground in Florida and those supporting
from our Region 4 office in Atlanta for
the extraordinary efforts that they have
put forth during this historic emergency
response
so we have been brought together here in
a moment when millions of Floridians are
navigating the aftermath of what is
going to be one of the most catastrophic
events they've experienced
my heart aches for those people who have
been in the path of hurricane Ian for
the lives that have been forever changed
by this storm and for the communities
that will simply never be the same
America woke up this morning to images
like Naples Punta Gorda and Cape Coral
submerged underwater homes across Fort
Myers that have been torn from their
foundations and boats that have been
found blocks away from their where they
were moored
but hurricane Ian is still a very
life-threatening storm we are expecting
the storm to continue making its way to
Georgia South Carolina and into North
Carolina maintaining tropical storm
force winds deadly storm surge and
rainfall of up to 12 inches
as many have said hurricane Ian is going
to be a storm that we talk about for
decades
but from the moment hurricane Ian became
a threat
we already had the right teams in place
who were ready to answer the call of
those that need us most
to the heroic First Responders and
search and rescue teams that have been
running towards danger to save lives to
the brave Medical Teams providing
compassionate and life-saving care to
the local state and federal emergency
managers working side by side to tackle
challenge after challenge
to our meteorological Partners who have
been providing us with critical weather
data hour after hour into the voluntary
Partners providing food and shelter to
those who have just lost everything
I thank you all of you we thank you and
our nation thanks you
now we know that the next few days are
going to be difficult we have some very
complex problems that we are going to
have to solve but like I said we have
the right teams in place who are ready
to help those who need us most
and as I shared with the president just
moments ago search and rescue missions
are already taking place across the
impacted areas by Land Air in Sea
we have teams ensuring critical Health
Facilities like hospitals and adult care
facilities have the support they need to
care for their patients or evacuate them
if still needed
we have power restoration teams making
their way into devastated communities
that help to help bring communities back
online
and while we are focused on life-saving
and life-sustaining response operations
we are already launching our recovery
mission
an interagency Recovery Group is already
planning for the long-term recovery
needs such as housing debris removal and
critical infrastructure repair as we
know this is going to be a complex
recovery
as you heard already the president
signed overnight a major disaster
declaration that unlocks critical
assistance to help these communities
jump start their road to recovery
individuals and families right now in
Charlotte Collier DeSoto Hardy Hillsboro
Lee Manatee Pinellas in Sarasota they
can now register for assistance and
begin their recovery process
you can register by visiting
disasterassistance.gov through our FEMA
app or by calling
1-800-621 FEMA 1-800-621-3362
and now that the Sun is up and we are
continuing to do our assessments we will
add more counties for individual
assistance
the next few days they're going to be
difficult we have some very complex
problems to solve but like I said we
have the right teams in place who are
ready to help those who need us most and
regardless of how bad it is I commit to
everyone here today that FEMA and our
partners across the federal state and
local levels remain ready and prepared
to help these communities in their
greatest time of need thank you
let me add one more thing we didn't
mention the the
Red Cross Red Cross is there they're
always there they stepped up and they
continue to step up so I want to thank
them as well thank you
it's totally irrelevant but I'll answer
it okay in fact very fine he
complimented me he thanked me for the
immediate response we had he told me how
much he appreciated it said he was
extremely happy with what's going on
this is not about whether anything
having to do with our disagreements
politically this is about saving
people's lives homes and businesses
that's what this is about and so I've
been I've talked to him four or five
times already and it's not a matter of
my disagreements with them on other
items Russia responsible for the rupture
of the North Street pipeline
let's stick with this okay
there's a lot of important International
students but we're here to talk about
America
okay thank you
thank you Mr President